I can't watch myself on screen too well
what am I should we pay 1250 to watch
your ass if you're not gonna all that
getting high the drinking the drugs and
everything else I did I showed up at the
theater every day and then when you go
to soak auditions and that doesn't
happen you say yourself what I really
need is one good national beer
commercial that's what I need he's a
prolific actor and film producer who's
appeared in over 100 movies he achieved
prominence in the early 1990s with films
like Patriot Games Jurassic Park and
pulp fiction he's ranked as the second
highest box-office star of all time with
box office earnings of almost five
billion dollars he's samuel l jackson
and here's my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number two is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips and as always a
Samuel says something that really means
helping to you please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes around us
or other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
listen there's so much that you don't
know about what will happen to you if
you become an actor or you become famous
that you know it all this is gravy you
know that's what it is but you're still
doing the work I mean this is not it's
about to work it's not about all the
others the others a byproduct of it now
you can buy into the others and and lose
yourself in it and lose yourself in the
most people tell you about yourself and
about you know kind of you do you know
everything I do is not great yeah good
but it ain't great I do good work and
some movies I know that that's happened
I know what they are they know what they
are but people watch them anyway because
there's something about them that made
me want to do it I enjoy myself doing it
he just didn't work out well but if you
buy into all this or you start
bullshitting yourself about what all
this is then you can give up in it I
read everything people write about me
hmm cuz I'm that kind of guy I remember
a lot of people that say bad about me
because I'm that kind of guy I Remedia
remember the people who write good [ __ ]
about me because I'm that kind of guy
we're in this business because it's a
look at me for business and if you say
you don't do that you're a liar you
light yourself you're lying to people
who watch you emails they go oh so fun
scream until well what a picture we pay
1250 to watch your ass if you're not
going you know if you if you can't watch
it I damn sure don't want to watch it i
watch my movies I want to see myself
when I was on stage I always wanted to
see the play i was in with me in it this
is the perfect venue for that hmm i
watch my movie some of my watch over and
over again if i'm channel surfing and
nothing else is on it i passed the movie
i'm in i'm in i'm not watching it cuz
that's what it is it's a look at me
business and i got into it because I
enjoyed the fantasy of it I love
make-believe I love movies I love
entertaining people that's what we do I
kept going I had
had I knew what my path was my path was
to become what I am right now now I lost
sight of it in an interesting sort of
way or I I went about it in a way we
path but fortunately for me all all the
all the getting hide the drinking the
drugs and everything else I did I showed
up at the theater every day I did please
ripped out of my mind I rehearsed ripped
out of my mind but every lesson that I
learned I held on to for some reason God
whatever somebody let me hold on to
everything that I was learning my stage
left on my stage rights my upstage foot
always out turn down this way learning
how to develop a character doing all
those things because those are things
that I love and I did them in the midst
of everything else that I was doing to
you know when when my friends were
getting ready to go get some more drugs
oh now I got to be at the theater then
I'll catch y'all on the theater though
you know when i'm done and I just I jet
oh I got to go build a set I got to do
this so I did everything that I had to
do so I was focused on this by any means
necessary plus I had a professor who was
like you know well you know all the
great ones do their jobs and hit ripped
out of their minds you know you look at
the bureau tools in the dirt yeah so
they get dropped me get hard they do
what they do but they show up and they
do this as though we were like okay and
that's what we did you know we drank
with him and we went to Styles vaknin
class we go smoke a joint come in and do
our other acting classes or go build a
set on a build some costumes hang some
like do all the things that we had to do
so I kept learning my lessons and doing
them how often do you find when you get
on set people are like do the Samuel do
the Sam Jackson thing do the samuel l
jackson thing that we know and love not
often yeah I don't know what that is I
mean
unless you say like eight times and you
know well crafted place but um me I
don't work I don't really know what that
is or to me the Sam Jackson thing is
I've I've read the script you know I
don't know how many times and I've
broken my character down the way I
learned to break a character down in the
theater if their source of material like
for George Washington Williams I'll go
to the source material and deal with
that but if not then okay it's up to me
to figure out who this guy is I can
figure out when he was born who his
parents were what his educational
background is military if he has that
what kind of life experiences he's had
how he feels about this that or the
other even down sometimes to what kind
of food eats you know just because
they're eating scenes in the movie and I
want to figure out what i want to eat
when I'm you know in that particular
scene and then from seeing the scene
what my relationship is with those
characters or what I'm trying to
accomplish in this scene that leads to
the next thing that leads to the next
thing that leads to the next thing so
what happens is the sam jackson thing
for me according to my agents and
managers is I'm so prepared when I show
up that I expect everybody else to be as
prepared as I am so when the director
does not have a shot list for that day
or directors floundering and trying to
figure out what he's doing he can ask me
and I can tell him you know because one
of funny things about movies is the
director is usually the person on the
film set it's got the least amount of
experience of everybody there
director a director makes one movie
every four years every two years yeah an
acronym a rector study that's what a
good directors chris 15 movies you know
everybody has done 15 movies the last
two years you know so we all know you
know I see shooting that then it gonna
be in the movie yeah it's like you don't
really need that shot yeah so des des
des chica what about that grace from
know that was amazing what do you jog
address somewhere but I sure prepared so
to me that's the Sam Jackson thing when
you hire me you had an actor who's going
to show up who gonna know his lands
gonna hit his marks and do his best to
make the other actors around him better
absolutely I'm not gonna call shots for
you and I don't expect you to give me a
line reading and if you do you had the
rum wear yellow actors have aspirations
and you look at movies and you look at
television and especially every year the
academy award show comes around and you
sit there and you say God I really would
love to be there what do I have to do to
get to that point you stand in the
mirror you do your you do your great
acceptance speech and all the things i
would say if i was up there who i would
think and as you keep working i often
tell people this now that what happened
to me was I actually kept working to the
point where I I started to do better
place and different kinds of directors
that I came into contact with and other
actors and interacting with him and the
craft became a lot more important but
that were times when I stopped wanting
to be a movie star and I say well okay i
can uh I can do a TV series sure I can
do a sitcom and then when you audition
for a few sitcoms you don't get that job
you say to yourself okay uh I can just
so yeah yeah I can send it to your
contractors so for a while and then when
you go to el sol auditions and that
doesn't happen you say to yourself what
I really need is one good national beer
commercial that's what I need a good
national beer commercial I can get those
checks coming every week
I keep my theater have it going but when
all this stuff doesn't happen and you
continue to work at your craft and you
do theater and you work with August
Wilson's and the Lloyd Richards and the
Duggars turn Awards of the world and the
Charles Fuller's you develop a way of
working and your craft becomes just one
of those great satisfying things that
you go through theatre every night you
have a different audience and people are
sitting there and you can feel the
sharing of energy being between you and
them they're giving you something you're
giving them something and at the end
every night there's a great reward that
long yeah and you're very satisfied with
that and once you let go of all those
dreams and aspirations and let your
respect for what you do become the most
important thing the other things start
to happen that was a point when I went
to auditions like everybody else no
matter what the movie was cuz I wanted
to be in the movies and I wanted to go
to work and I had no choice going to
work was the option so generally I
didn't see the script anyway they gave
you eight pages asides what seems in
them and you might have got the script
later after you got the job they give
you the script you know and I just look
through and see what page that died on
and that was it but when you're out of
the audition process and you're sitting
at home and you're making choices then
you should make choices that are
satisfying to you in some way and not
monetarily right they should be
satisfying to you artistically they
should appeal to you as an actor or as
an audience member or as a person who
wants to make people excited when they
come to the movies and see you do this
you know it shouldn't be based on you
know all that other you know both about
you know this is who they think I am so
I have I become this kind of actor and
people appreciate me for this this is
one thing I used to like about Jim
Carrey everybody wanted to go watch them
Carrie laughs you know and be funny but
Jim tried all the stuff you know
sometimes it works sometimes it didn't
but he wasn't gonna be painted in it
into that corner right that you're not
gonna
I'm not just just gonna do comedies you
know I don't have to be the three
stooges I don't have to be you know WC
Fields I don't have to be chaplain I
don't have to be you know a name I don't
have to be John Wayne I can be all these
other things and I want to try and be
them and he made an effort to be that
and when I came into this business from
the theater I didn't do the same kind of
play all the time I did all kinds of
plays that it all kinds of characters
and this is a bigger venue for doing
that they get better makeup artists they
have better scripts they put you in the
environment you don't have to convince
somebody you're in the environment it's
there they put you in it so why not do
and many different things as you're
capable of doing and that was my my
thought I want to do as wide a variety
of genres of film as I can just to you
know continue to see if I can stretch
myself as an actor but then I was in the
die-hard office one day and there's a
sign on the on the on the wall that I
adhere to family now that said be
careful of the toes you step on today
for they could be connected to the ass
you'll have to kiss tomorrow and believe
me they're been pas and other people
like when I'm on a movie set I think
everybody is just as important as I am I
treat them that way so I know pas names
I talked to him I speak to him every day
I speak to the gaffer's and speak to the
grips I speak to all these people and
over the years I've gotten jobs and the
producer will show up and he'll be like
you don't remember me but I was a PA on
our son son son you were so nice to me
that you know I was doing this movie I
couldn't help but think you know that
you would be the perfect and that [ __ ]
works out you know or they become
writers so they become directors you
know but it's a collaborative effort I
mean we're we're almost the least
important element of any film because if
they putting the lights up right or the
sound man mike is jacked up it'll mean
about what you're doing cuz nobody can
see you or hear you you know so they can
fix that in the mix you know but
everything else has got to work and you
you have to know that I dreamed about
being an actor
for very long time why I was fooling
myself thinking I wanted to be an
oceanographer I'll never know I always
always thought I wanted to be the black
Jacques Cousteau I just wanted to hang
out in the world I always thought inner
space was much more exciting than outer
space so I figured I'd go underwater and
hang out I like to dive and do stuff
like that but I've loved movie since I
was a kid I spent a lot of my time in
the movies when I was a kid and I
watched a lot of movies I still spend an
inordinate amount of my time watching
movies I collect asian film so I watch a
lot of chinese japanese thai Korean
Koreans making really great films these
days indonesian films like I just like
asian film it's more visual and it
stimulates me in another way but I grew
up watching movies and imagining myself
on screen so aside from the very serious
things that I do I will occasionally do
a snakes on a plane because
those are the kind of movies I like when
I was a kid I always wanted to see
myself in a movie with a bunch of snakes
and I'm I'm still trying to find the
right no slasher movie to do because I
like slasher movies and I'm still you
know I did things like deep blue sea
because I wanted to run from something
that had big teeth and Harlan Elster so
I'm not that serious about it you know I
I really think movie should be fun and I
think they should be entertaining if I
want to teach you something i'll do a
documentary but I do this because it
feeds me it feeds my artistic sense a
lot of people think i do too many movies
i read an article in paper yesterday
about me doing too many movies but you
know writers get up and write every day
painters get up in pain every day actors
only have so many acting opportunities
in a lifetime i'm going to take mine as
they come and do as many movies as I can
before them up out of here so something
like Avengers it seemed like you were
having a great time I am NOT a great not
a huge acting challenge for you I
imagined by the bins you seem to be
having fun what fun is important this
should be a fun job it's make-believe is
it you and your friends with real
costumes and better guns and doing the
thing you know exciting people it's
that's what that's about when you're
doing something like the Avengers you
got to take it seriously in in in terms
of you believe the space your end you
believe the world and the convention of
it that there are people who can do [ __ ]
greater than normal human beings can do
trust that go with it treat them like
they're those kinds of people and they
have an element of danger and an element
of all that comes with all that that's
the honesty of the world but you know
I'm [ __ ] nick fury I got some with me
too so I can be you know boom I can
stand up to him and say what I need to
say and sometimes like any Avengers I
need to manipulate these people I got to
where I am because I'm Nick Fury I can
do something with me nobody knows how
old i am or why I'm still still alive
well why I'm now black when I used to be
white you know so i guess with me too so
you could you accept that and you go
with it and you treat it like a summer
honest and you treat it like a son
real selling when people come and see it
they don't see you going you know I'm in
it hmm i'm in it is some dangerous
happening and you can help us fix that
so let's go get them that's like you and
your friends doing this when you were
kids let's go get him go get over you
know and then you shoot him making say
you missed cut the chest blow up and all
that kind of yeah that's great cuz I'm i
just happen to do a British talk show
and this guy asked me there were any
directors that never worked with that I
wanted to work with and I realized
George was about to start Star Wars I
said I'd love to work with George Lucas
and somebody that worked for him told
him because they were doing
pre-production in London and I left
there I went to San Francisco and I was
doing sphere I didn't know the napa
valley somewhere and I got a call they
said George wants to meet with you if
you're really serious about being in
Star Wars looks like great so it's not a
car I went over to the ranch I met with
him and you know he was like you know
I've seen a couple things you're in but
I don't really you know I'm like well
you don't have to no it's okay you know
I just want to be in the movie evening
like well I don't know what I'm like
what look I'll be a stormtrooper I just
want to run across the square nobody
needs to know him in this movie but me
you know i will run across the screen
with a white
how did it happy because I just wanted
to be in a Star Wars movie you were a
Jedi Knight no I had no idea until they
call I left there jordan says well you
know um they got a couple things I got
some palace guard stuff you know maybe
was blue well we'll find something and I
was like okay great so I went off and it
was like three months later I was done
with sphere and I was ready to do
something else I gotta call it said
George wants you to come to London can
you come to London now sure gonna plane
i go to london i get to studio they take
me to this dressing room and mind you i
still haven't seen a script I'm saying
anything but you already were willing to
do house here's the thing i didn't care
you you collect like little figurines
right yeah so is that what you were
angling for is i want i want to be a
star wars on hurry I just wanted to be
in Star Wars yeah you don't understand
when i SAT there saw that movie for the
first time I saw sitting us into myself
how in the hell do you get in something
like this right yeah what do you have to
do and then you know I another movie
like diehard my friend Reginald villas
that cop this outside eating donuts oh
oh my how'd it Reggie get that job so
there are certain things that you watch
that you just want to do so when I got
there and I was in in my dressing room
or what they said with my dressing room
they go well somebody would be up here
to help you put on your costume in a
minute you haven't fitting and cool so I
was after wonder whose dressing room
this is because I see some boots and I
see well looks like a Jedi robe I must
be in somebody's room then somebody came
in and gave me the three pages and got
busier lines and I went mace windu the
hell is that you know and it's just mace
windu Yoda mace windu Yoda mace windu
Yoda I know I'm not Yoda
you didn't know who this guy was and
then they came in you know I put on the
boots and they start putting stuff on me
I'm like so I'm a Jedi anyway well yeah
right Wow and I'm having a conversation
with Yoda so I guess I won't be edited
out of the movie so I won't be just
running across screen and then the guy
came in with the Halliburton and he's
like pick your lightsaber handle now you
know I can't even tell you what I really
did I just I really just look like
and that was I was like oh my god so
that one so that's when I knew I was a
Jedi and it was didn't think there'd be
a little ceremony where you be I didn't
know what was going to happen at that
point all I knew was I was a Jedi I had
my lightsaber they told me to go in this
room I met Frank Oz and all these guys
cuz yer was still a puppet man right so
I had to rehearse with these guys for
like hours and hours while he did ears
and eyes and Yoda stuffing I was very
cool with all that but I made it my man
in I was like okay so i just got to be
cool and not get George any grief be
quiet stay out of the way and see how
long I hang around don't let him kill me
don't kill him don't and that's what I
didn't the first move yet sat in the
chair know you know everybody was having
lightsaber battles I want to do it like
mmm let it go let it go I'm fine you'll
get to it and I made it through the
first one so the second one actually
sent me a script and I'm reading it and
I see oh wow that's a huge huge battle
thing in this arena and I'm in it but
it's like we've called Jedi's from all
over the galaxy two fighting this arena
I'm like I don't hell am I gonna find
myself and all this big old fight George
you think I could have like a purple
lightsaber no Sam there give you the red
or they're green I'm free but I'm you
know on the second baddest Jedi in the
universe and I've been around for a
while you know and purple it's kind of
in the middle could be like Kevin kind
of dope when he said let me think about
it I didn't bother I go away we shoot
the movie in Australia then we do
reshoots in London no I got something to
show you man he pulls it up and sure
enough purple lightsaber I'm oh
but George's feel you know Georgia
stealing that space where I don't know
if we let you keep that though because
somehow we got leaked on the net that's
causing this big storm I'm like really I
wonder who leaked that and eventually I
got to keep it but I just really you
know it's only because I was just vanity
I'm trying to find myself in that big
old fight in the middle of the arena
it's not where it should totally work
only works I know where I am and that
they go fight but you know George is
great like that georges georges like me
I like George and it all worked out and
he finally told me said well you know
you're gonna you're gonna die in episode
3 all right why well I've already done
it was so four five and six and you're
not at all and you're the only
significant character that I can kill
that will make a difference that moves
the story along I want too happy about
it's like what can I just like get my
hand cut off and fall out the window and
not really be dead right well that would
mean you'd have to wait 2 episode 7 to
come back to be able to be something but
I'm okay with that I had my moment it
was great the Lucas give it in the Lucas
take away yeah but you know it's the
yeah good run it's like the gift that
keeps on giving they just they just
re-released what all that stuff on
blu-ray and stuff so I got another check
I'm good
excuse me um mr. l jackson i just
watched chef for the first time oh very
cool and you know that part where you
say it's my duty to please that booty
indeed I do you um well my daughter's
said it to her principal and now she's
suspended from school and it's all your
fault oh well I was just acting a movie
you Samuel Jackson hey samuel l jackson
I'm a huge fan I've loved you in
Jurassic Park well thanks very much yeah
except for the fact that you smoke in it
and my kids addicted to cigarettes now
you monster hey hey hey a lot of people
smoking movies I'm not the only one okay
and if I'm not mistaken that's a
cigarette right it's your fault my kids
folks whose samuel l jackson hey samuel
l jackson oh man my son and i just saw
you in coach Carter oh great big yeah I
mean it really taught him to believe in
himself awesome glad I could do that for
him but he really sucks at basketball so
you should really quit you know in a
sense of style is completely off because
you played or dell and Jackie Brown so
you samuel l jackson hey but your mind
signing my kids wallet
it's two dollars all right samuel l
jackson please don't start telling me
about how my movies are screwed up your
kids okay no actually I was gonna say
you were great and unbreakable hey my
man yeah too bad my kids a super villain
that commits heinous crimes for his own
sick amusement nós somos attacked by a
shark because you saw you in deep blue
sea how's that even my fault my son has
a 22 year old overweight nerd living in
my basement because you decided to do
Star Wars yeah and my son has a severe
peanut allergy because of you my
nicknames Gator not smoke crack because
of dog a favor no I never saw that just
like crack what there is hey hey you
stalking me I have a son who's in prison
because you were in Shawshank Redemption
what Mimi I was Morgan Freeman well you
anyway I got a kid who's an insomniac
because you never sleep in your movies
my three-year-old saw you and Django
Unchained no she can't stop saying the
n-word you let your kid watched Django
okay everybody listen I know I've made
some bad dudes in movies okay but my
pictures on the poster maybe your kid
shouldn't watch it don't you people read
the descriptions of these movies before
you show them to your kids huh look at
the right end rating for that your
responsibility not mine thank you very
much get some help for that great
problem man oh yeah see I can be a month
Roma
thank you very much appreciate your time
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed i made this video
because Dimitri George ever asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you are made of profile next leave it
down the comments below I don't see what
I can do I also love to know which of
the top 10 rules the biggest impact on
you and why what did you learn from this
what are you going to apply to your
business or your life leave in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout-out to morale i hope i pronounced
that ok thank you so much for picking up
a copy my book it really really really
means a lot to me so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
guys I'll see you soon
I didn't get your name I got yours
Vincent right but but I never got my
name's pit and you ain't talking your
way out of this no I just want you to
know how I just want you to know how
sorry we are that that things got so up
with us and mr. Wallace yeah when we got
into this thing with the best intentions
really I never oh I'm sorry did I break
your concentration I didn't mean to do
that please continue you were saying
something about best intentions what's
the matter oh you're finished oh well
allow me to retort what does marcellus
wallace look like what country are you
from [ __ ] watch what ain't no country I
ever heard of let's be ingerson what
what English do you speak it yes and you
know what I'm saying describe what
Marsellus Wallace looks like it's like
what I did say what again I dare you I
double dare you say what one more
goddamn time splat cause he's bald does
he look like a [ __ ] what does he look
like a [ __ ] oh and why you trying like
a [ __ ] Britt did yes you did yes you
did read you tried to do myself violence
don't like to be by anybody except mrs.
watts you read the Bible right yes well
there's this passage I got never a sort
of [ __ ] occasion ezekiel 25 17 the
path of the righteous man is beset on
all sides by the inequities of the
selfish and the tyranny of evil men
blessed is he who in the name of charity
and goodwill separates the weak through
the valley of darkness well he is truly
his brother's keeper and the finder of
lost children die will strike down upon
thee with great vengeance and furious
anger those who attempt to poison and
destroy my brothers and you will know my
name is the Lord when I lay my vengeance
upon thee daddy would you relax a little
bit relaxed but let me give you some
advice never say no to a hostage taker
it's in the manual now are you gonna
tell me no again no no wrong answer no
Polly never use no don't want or can't
all right it eliminates options the only
option that leaves is to shoot someone
understand Hey yes yes good yes good you
say no again I'll kill somebody all
right now let's practice can I see a
priest all right let's not you know what
can we can we just like talked want to
talk we are talking now can I see a
priest uh I'll see what I can do that's
good Farley now you're learning I'd like
a submachine gun so I can blow everyone
away oh look into that good you're doing
good Farley you ever cheat on your wife
Farley no watch yourself I'll kill
someone you ever cheat on your wife
answer I'll see what I can do think
about that um I'll look into that you
ever um dress up like a schoolgirl and
get your ass bank Farley Danny look okay
all I want to do is just talk to you I'm
talking now did you or did you not ever
guess up like a schoolgirl and get your
ass spanked have to look into that
Daniel please follow you know nothing
against you dressing up like a little
girl
I didn't know that about you from Danny
you know this is really really
unproductive unproductive you're right
it is so tell me a joke probably you
know any jokes no no you just cost
someone their life Farley game over
shot fired shot
wha you can't talk me down you can't
make me change the deadline now get me
Savior you got six minutes 42 41
anything on the way anybody hurt we're
okay just don't be saying no no more I
just have one more thing crew did you
have to repeat your orders to captain
Lee sorry you ordered captain Lee to
engage hostile targets and he advised
you that there were women and children
in the line of fire is that correct well
he couldn't see yes or no colonel did he
follow your first set of orders I don't
remember captain Lee is on record as
saying he hesitated and mentioned the
snipers in the buildings is his
testimony accurate I don't remember let
me get this straight you evacuate the
ambassador you go back to the roof two
of you Marines or ki a a third sergeant
crassa [ __ ] dies you give you captain
and order which he doesn't follow in
fact he questions and then you said what
I don't remember you don't remember what
you said next it was combat not some
training a moment later your men was
shooting what did you say to make that
happen I don't know you must have said
something captain Lee reversed himself
what did you say I don't know the exact
words let me help you your honor you
said waste them didn't you no no no
didn't say it well it all happened so
fast they're under oath colonel let me
refresh your memory this is exhibit cue
a tape recording made aboard the USS
wake island of all radio communications
receive that day including your exact
words your honor with your permission I
would like to play this tape well if you
got it on tape then that's what I said
then we're killing my Marines so yeah
waste them he's the subjection overruled
yes these objection yes thus objection
overruled yes are these them did you
want it to be wasted your honor major
yeah Your Honor the crowd in front of
the embassy had no weapons did they
colonel objection we've had no snipers
weapons either yes they had weapons you
think there's a strip for fighting a war
without pissing somebody off follow the
rules and nobody gets hurt yes innocent
people probably died innocent people
always die but I did not exceed my are
there are rules and Marines are sworn to
uphold I was not going to stand by and
see another marine die just to live by
those rules cuddle